Speaker 1: Hey, here's something kind
of I don't know that that it's funny,
but it's certainly interesting. Somehow,
Georgia Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker managed to do another press event. And at
this event, he was joined by Republican Senators
Tom Cotton and Rick Scott, two horrible
people. Walker did his normal routine,
where he tells unintelligible stories in an
incoherent way. And you can visibly see Cotton
and Scott cringing where they clearly seem to
be thinking, What the hell am I doing here? I
don't know who thinks these events are good ideas.
Here is Herschel Walker railing against pronouns.
I'm going to take a position against adverbs if
I ever run for something. But Walker focused on
pronouns and just look at the looks on cotton
and Scott's faces, trying to act as though
this is normal when they clearly know it is not.
Speaker 2: Hey, just think about it. Pronoun in
our military. How do you identify in our military?
It is a real times. What happened to push ups and
sit ups. Because I can tell you right now, China,
Iran and Russia are not talking about pronouns.
Speaker 1: Right. Tom Cotton, looking particularly
pained as this is going on. Here is another one
of Herschel Walker's great stories about
a bear and a dog and something about how
he's responding to the abortion scandal. Yeah.
Speaker 2: They'll do whatever it takes. Will say
whatever they have to say because they want this
seat right here. But I don't think they know that
they will go for Boehner.
Speaker 6: Right.
Speaker 2: But hey, I'm not
just a dog now. I'm a bear.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And I got a couple emails from
some of our viewers in the LGBT community saying,
does he understand what bears are in
the LGBT community? I'm sure he doesn't.
And then last clip here, Herschel
Walker again tries telling the story
about the bulls and the cows in the field. Every
time he tells the story, the story is different.
And again here, Rick Scott looking particularly
demoralized at having to stand up there.
Speaker 2: And they've been saying something is
better somewhere else. And I'm here to tell you
is not. So I've been telling this little story
about this book out in the field with six cows.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: And three. I'm a pregnant.
So, you know, he's got something going on, but all
he cares about is kept his nose against the fence,
looking at three other cows that didn't belong to
him. Now all he had to do is eat grass. But no,
no, no. He does not have a beer somewhere else.
So he decided, I want to get over there. So one
day you measure that fence up and you say, I
think I can jump this. So they came. We got back
and he got back in and he took off running.
He done it better, got good up on the bottom.
But as he made it over on the other side, he took
it off. He got so excited about it and he ran to
the top of the hill. But when he got up there,
he realized they were bulls, too. So what I'm
telling you, I don't think is buried somewhere.
Speaker 1: I think that maybe this is a version of
a bird in the hand is worth two in the bush or
the grass isn't really greener on the other side
or something like that. So of course, as I've
been telling you, we are very closely monitoring
the polling data and it is still quite tight. We
have a couple of new polls. Walker versus Warnock,
Raphael Warnock is now winning by an average of
3.3. There is a new Trafalgar poll that basically
has this even with Warnock plus one. As insane
as it is, this guy should be losing by 50. WALKER
He's still in the race. And so it is going to take
more to knock this guy out of the race. It will
probably go until the last minute on Election Day,
but continuing to humiliate himself and who thinks
these press conferences are good ideas? We'll
take a quick break and be back after this. Yes,
right wing media fell for a Black Lives Matter
Antifa hoax. We will talk about it next.